Alex Haslem was a social psychologist
has done a lot of research and he truly
believes that you are your social groups
and the people you interact with in
social groups really make up a huge part
of your identity and he's going to tell
that story Alex is a social psychologist
he's based at the University of Exeter
in England and he is an innovator in
studying the relationship between
individual identity and group identities
please welcome Alex hazard
I'm going to make the argument answering
that question is absolutely fundamental
if we want to understand social behavior
that all social behavior is informed by
people's sense of self so you know how
if you're a woman and you've got
children how you define yourself as a
mother it's going to affect how you
bring up your children if you're working
in an organization how you see yourself
in that organization is going to affect
your behavior in that organization and I
would argue that if you like the self as
a core psychological construct is at the
center of social behavior and you can
never understand any form of social
behavior without engaging in the
psychological constructs that underpin
it and fundamental to that are issues of
identity so I would argue that the
question of identity is the big question
in social science let's just start by
thinking about if I said to you who I
you know Who am I well I'm an individual
I'm Alex I'm Irene or inclined and
that's surely then the nature of
identity is bound up in our individual
experiences our sense of ourselves as I
and if I wanted to understand my own
identity what I would need to do is kind
of renewed remove myself from social
contact and kind of go deeper and deeper
into that personal self and this is a
little experiment that a BBC journalist
conducted recently and this journalist
went to live as a hermit in in the
mountains of Mid Wales and what did he
find this is what he said in this book
what I found was not what he might
expect you might think that such
protracted solitude would lead to an
introspection to grow in self-awareness
but not for me what happened was that I
began to forget myself my focus shifted
almost entirely outwards
It was as if we gained our sense of self
from our interaction with other people
alone there was no need for identity for
self definition so actually going deeper
and deeper into the personal self
becoming more of an I actually you lose
contact with you I bet
actually the self and our sense of self
is actually incredibly fluid and one of
the reasons for that is that the self
our sense of self is actually a category
we can think of ourselves as individuals
I Alex or I can think of myself as a
group member and I can think of myself
as a member of different groups I can
say I'm British or I can say I'm a
social scientist or a male so the
question is when do particular
identities become salient again you
might think that's a simple question
actually it's peculiarly complicated in
if I were to answer in a single sentence
the answer is to when we define
ourselves in terms of a particular
identity is when it makes sense to do so
you're more likely to define yourself as
Canadian if you're watching Canada play
sports and the Olympics that comparative
context makes that identity salient if
the sport in some sense of activity is
typical of the identity so you're more
likely to feel Canadian if you're
watching ice hockey even if you're
watching a field hockey program you're
watching tennis and also if being
Canadian has meant something to you in
the class then we tend to see ourselves
as similar to other members of that
category of that group so if you had all
just if you happen to bump into each
other under on the metro on the way here
you wouldn't have felt you had any in
common with the person sitting next to
you but now that you're in this room and
your relationship to that other person
is defined by the shared identity you
know you feel that sense of commonality
feel closer to them you're more likely
to listen to them and think they have
something interesting to say to you and
then by the same token they're more
likely to think that you have something
interesting to say to their
if I define myself in terms of a social
group based identity and identity that I
share with someone else like us our
social scientists as men or as
supporters of this particular football
team then I if you like seek out other
members of that group and I will work
together with other people who have that
identity to organize our behavior in
meaningful ways and achieve group
relevant outcomes without social
identity without that sense of busters
we couldn't engage in the collaborative
activities that if you like propel
society forward now again you will work
in your organizations what I would say
central to the ability of those
organizations to work is a sense of
shared identity and indeed some other
work we've recently done a talk with an
i and colleagues at recently published
makes the point that leadership is a
process is entirely contingent upon
shared identity and we show that groups
that don't have shared identity cannot
have the experience of leadership
something fundamental to human society
is this a matter of life and death yes
it is
social identities make us human and that
they make life worth living the biggest
threat to health that individuals face
throughout the lifespan is social
isolation that's the biggest killer
that's out there one of the reasons we
don't focus on the consequences of
social isolation is you come here the
drug so drug companies can't make a lot
of money out of if you like a cure and
dealing with that particular problem
actually that's a problem we have to do
with that ourselves so the question is
and they gather question of myself and
my colleagues it's Steve Bowen our group
really address very fundamental ease
what can we do anything about that if a
sense of identity loss has kind of
compromised health and well-being can we
do anything to create a sense of shared
identity that will feed into positive
health outcomes and indeed one of the
great problems of a contemporary society
is that we have too many lonely people
in
when in their lives the people are made
they're most likely to experience
profound identity loss and is very much
towards the end of people's lives when
they retire and in particular if they
have to move into a care facility like a
residential care and that was we we
looked at in this study we were looking
at a care home where the care staff were
worried that a lot of the residents have
become very isolated and they weren't
using communal facilities in particular
they weren't using the lounges in the
wings where their own rooms were located
so what the staff had suggested was that
they had a plan to kind of redecorate
them just because they become Dowdy's on
and maybe by redecorating and freshening
them up they would enhance that you know
make just make people feel more positive
about that more likely to use those we
had a control condition in a care home
where two wings had no redecoration
whatsoever that was a kind of a baseline
we had another wing in which the
residents moved into that ring and it
was beautifully redecorated with to the
highest possible standard on the basis
of decisions that had been made by the
staff on the basis of their prior
experience but the residents were not
involved in those decisions and in the
third conditions what we did the third
condition we got wings involved as
groups in the process of making
decisions about the deck or in those
view wings this is what we found this is
social identification in the baseline
condition over time you notice any
difference and the same is true in the
control in the control condition where
the decisions were made for the
residents where they are empowered
though as you would predict the resident
started to feel connected to the other
residents they felt that the person in
the room next bulletin was no longer
stranger and the staff same so they felt
more part of the community how did that
affect on their life satisfaction well
as you'd expect in a baseline condition
in the control condition
changed but in the empowered condition
where they come together as a group
you've got a massive increase in life
satisfaction various the nuts associated
with significant drops in depression
clinical depression
it was also associated cognitive
publicly involved in a group feeling
part of the community if you might
infuse people with a motivation to
actually engage and what we saw was
particularly increases in memory and
language functioning if you like aspects
of cognitive functioning that are
strictly motivational so people were
motivated to engage if you create an
intelligent community in which people
engage then you can enhance that that
cognitive performance if you look at the
control conditions what she says over
time people were not more likely to use
their lounges in fact of decoration they
were less likely to use their lounges
why because they didn't recognize them
anymore there were horrible places
they've come in woman one woman
expressed complete surprise
she thought you've been moved into
another home but amongst those people
who've been involved in the process of
change what you see is a massive it is
in fact a three-fold increase in that
use of space so again the cure for
social isolation isn't just to create a
better environment it's to engage people
as collectives in the process of
transforming those if you like giving
you the theory that identities are
really important for social behavior in
fact that fundamentally I'd say that
social identities they're a source of
pleasure we feel good because we're
members of groups but more fundamentally
they actually give our lives meaning and
they give us purpose you can't have
football teams you can't have Nations
you can't have companies you can't have
television production companies you
can't have social science without the
people who are party to that sharing a
sense of identity that provides them
with a motivation and an intellectual
framework that allows them to coordinate
their behavior in meaningful ways and
produce key social outcomes so yes
is unique but actually we all belong to
a constellation of different brews that
give us each a different category
different fabrication to art itself but
actually our individuality is the most
profound expression of sociality and by
the point I'd make is but to understand
the self thing we should not turn
inwards and if you like down the
microscope and so on and look deeper and
deeper into our genetics or independent
of the society from which we come that
actually to understand the self we need
to turn towards society not away
you